avec nous à ottawa la ministre des
finances christophe gijon bonsoir madame
freeland
bonsoir gérait le gros morceau vraiment
de votre budget c'est l'immobilier la
propriété et ce conte d'epargne pour
l'achat d'une première propriété dans
quelle mesure ce nouveau conte va aider
les gens à accéder véritablement à la
propriété
je pense beaucoup
parce que je sais qu'aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas une situation juste
pour les jeunes canadiennes c'est trop
difficile aujourd'hui pour les jeunes
canadiennes les gens qui veulent faire
tous les bonnes choses
qu'ils veulent vraiment acheter une
maison est ce qu'on va aider les
canadiennes chaque année du mètre à côté
une poudre de l'argent pour se
permetttre acheter une maison et pour
moi c'est une mesure économique parce
que le logement c'est vraiment c'est une
enjeu social est une enjeux économiques
et c'est aussi une question de la
justice intergénérationnelle
parce que moi nos amis nous avons déjà
des maisons mais comme je pars avec mes
enfants ses amis c'est difficile pour
eux de penser qu'il que ce sera possible
pour eux d'acheter une maison vous avez
raison en même temps se demande si une
mesure comme celle là avec les prix qui
augmentent tellement présentement est ce
que ça pourrait favoriser
encourager alimenter la demande
davantage et faire grimper les prix
davantage
c'est une bonne question
et je suis d'accord avec vous que
la chose la plus important en ce qui
concerne le logement c'est
l'approvisionnement de logements et
quand on a étudié la question de
logement le défi de logement au canada
on à conclure que la chose la plus
importante c'est dû construire
plus d'une maison au canada alors vous
pouvez
madame swing de que vous annoncer
aujourd'hui mais est-ce que c'est assez
la banque scotia très récemment ça
prendrait presque 2 millions de
logements supplémentaires au canada
est-ce que 100000 c'est suffisant pour
pour combler le manque de logements nous
avons
j'étais en net et clair dans la chambre
des communes aujourd'hui et j'ai dit que
parce que je pense que c'est très
important d'être honnête et réaliste en
ce qui concerne le logement ce n'est
c'est une grande grande en jeu et il n'y
a pas une programme ou même une budget
qui peut dans une moment résoudre tous
les défis autour de l'ange mans ce sera
une question de faire des
investissements année par année par
année mais je veux dire que le programme
dont le budget que j'ai présentée
aujourd'hui c'est le clou ambitieuse
plein qu'aucun gouvernement fédéral a
proposé qu'une bombe bébé ok sur
l'inflation le coût de la vie ça
préoccupe tout le monde présentement le
coût de la vie vous ne baissez pas les
taxes notamment sur les sens et il n'y a
pas de soutien exceptionnel large comme
on a vu au gouvernement du québec a
décidé de donner 500 dollars presque
tout le monde pourquoi vous vous ne
faites pas ça
gerald vous avez juste me demander si
j'ai pensé si des mesures dont le budget
vont augmenter les pressions
inflationnistes
c'était l'idée dans votre question
concernant le logement oui c'était les
deux joueuses des prix et propriété mais
on pensait que de les donner de l'argent
ce serait inflationnistes c'est ça
je veux dire que en créant le budget on
a fait beaucoup d'attention à la
situation macroéconomique
et on a fait beaucoup
d'attention à ne pas faire des choses
qui vont créer une pire situation elle
c'est pour cette raison que on a faut
pousser les mesures sur la croissance la
croissance de la capacité économique en
même temps je comprends que
l'abordabilité et une grève question
pour les canadiens et on a beaucoup des
mesures
dans le budget et dont les budgets
précédents qui vont aider les familles
les plus vulnérables aux que la location
canadienne pour les enfants les
allocations pour les années et ce sont
des mesures qui
vont être à un niveau plus haut avec de
l'inflation pourquoi un moment de forte
croissance économique comme c'est le cas
présentement avec un très faible taux de
chômage
pourquoi vous n'allez pas jusqu'à l'
équilibre budgétaire pourquoi vous ne
l'annoncé pas j'ai l'impression adam
freeland que votre gouvernement est
allergique à ce mot équilibre budgétaire
pourquoi
notre gouvernement
adore le mot responsabilité
responsabilité fiscale et c'est une
budget qui démontre une responsabilité
fiscale dans laquelle les canadiens et
canadiennes peut avoir beaucoup de
confiance et en créant le budget pour
moi c'est très important de regarder la
situation internationale et de voir
qu'est ce que font les autres pays
industrialisés parce que en bout ligne
le canada a fait seulement une partie
d'une économie mondiale et je peux
assurer les canadiens canadiennes que
notre approche est le plus responsable
de tous les pays du g7 en ce qui
concerne la dette et en ce qui concerne
les déficits est-ce que d'offrir un
crédit d'impôt aux au captage et au
stockage du carbone
est ce que c'est une nouvelle forme de
subventions au secteur énergétique
non
mais pourquoi j'ai pu m'expliquer le wii
speak
pour deux raisons premièrement ce crédit
est essentiel pour permettre le canada à
avoir une action climatique efficace
nous savons tous que le secteur
énergétique doit
contribuer à l'action climatique est ce
programme va le permettre à le faire le
crédit est aussi créé très strictement
pour ne peut ne peux me permettre pas
l'utilisation de ce crédit dans la
production du pétrole je comprends je
comprends mais on a l'impression et
surtout avec l'annnonce de bilge nord
hier à terre-neuve et labrador que c'est
bien mais ce com com com comme mesures
pour atteindre nos cibles de réduction
de gaz à effet de serre parce que non
seulement faut investir pour l'avenir
mais il faut atteindre nos cibles de
2030 est ce que le captage et le
stockage de carbone est une vraie bonne
solution pour l'avenir
le captage est nécessaire pour réussir à
pour nos cibles nos cibles ne seront pas
possible pour nous sont le cac pages
donc c'était vraiment captage et le
stockage du carbone
le captage est une méthode très
importants pour diminuer les émissions
du secteur énergétique et c'est très
important pour nos cibles pour le plan
climatique de madame frieden on vous
laisse aller merci d'avoir été avec nous
ce soir
merci beaucoup